now to an issue facing every american
household the labor department says
inflation has hit a 31-year high price
is rising at more than double the rate
we've seen in recent decades the
president says it's a top priority to
get it under control
new government figures show beef prices
are up 20 percent since last year
furniture up 12 percent new cars nearly
10 percent the largest one-year increase
since 1975.
even rent for the average apartment has
shot up by more than a hundred dollars a
month cover nineteen has stretched
global supply chains like never before
in baltimore this week president biden
insisted the problem is temporary and
touted the 17 billion dollars in the
newly passed infrastructure bill that
will go to modernize ports but that
won't happen fast enough to ease the
current supply crunch we've got higher
demand for goods at the same time we're
facing disruptions in the supplies to
make those goods prices typically rise
about two to three percent a year but
since a year ago they've shot up more
than six percent it's not just a u.s
problem this is a global problem moody's
chief economist says he thinks inflation
should dissipate in 2022
if we keep the pandemic at bay
there's also a big ticket item that he
recommends holding off on purchasing
anytime soon cars vehicles i mean
to be real though even if you wanted to
buy one you might not be able to find
one there's only believe it or not
there's only 75 000
cars on dealer lots today in a typical
time it's closer to 500 000
and we're told even if inflation starts
to subside next year it could take up to
two years to iron out all the supply
chain backups